hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we'll
see how we are in the last days of the
month of love digging in let's wipe this
shit I have a question about love
concerning what is possibly one of the
greatest love stories of all time
does Romeo and Juliet suck okay let me
be a little bit more specific does Romeo
and Juliet suck as a love story
everyone always regards is one of the
best if not the best story about love
out there
it's Shakespeare's best-known play
outside of Hamlet and is one of the most
celebrated but when you get down to it
what really happens in the tale two
families are at war with each other two
star-crossed lovers from each side see
each other at first glance and decide
they're in love the two families say is
forbidden and can't believe I'm saying
this but spoilers they end up taking
their lives because they can't live
without one another the ultimate in
poetry the ultimate in sorrow but the
ultimate in romance
well let's look at how our two leads
fell in love they see each other mo
they're in love yeah Minute Rice takes
longer than that now granted a lot of
this comes down to whether or not you
believe in the notion of love at first
sight which is an ideal that seems to be
dying more and more every day and
honestly with good reason
appearances can be deceiving and just
because someone looks like a perfect
mate doesn't necessarily mean they are
personalities obviously play a much
larger role in whether or not a
relationship will survive
so basing your ideal love just on their
appearance is probably not the wisest
now that's not to say it can't happen
it's perfectly possible that the person
you are visually most attracted to may
also have the exact traits that you need
in a relationship as well but I think
most of us can agree it's pretty rare
but how they meet is one thing how about
the chemistry they share together well
from a dramatic standpoint that's pretty
weak - aside from just saying how much
they love each other they never
there any real moments they never
discovered they have anything in common
they never compare their likes and their
dislikes they don't discuss their future
they don't discuss their past they just
keep talking about how great it is to be
in love and I think a lot of people
would question does that really hold
much water in terms of a relationship
well what do we know about them
individually well we know they're both
risk takers
take care much about their family but
not to a point where they want to be ran
by them we know they're determined
emotional angry but can still find the
soft side and show their sensitivities
to that special someone so the
characters themselves are not really
flat but I think most can argue that
their chemistry is even romances that a
lot of people hate like The Notebook
love story and yes even Twilight
technically have more chemistry than
Romeo and Juliet do yes you heard it
right here Bella and Edward technically
have more chemistry than Romeo and
Juliet why because even though they're
done poorly they do have a base to start
from they do talk to one another about
their problems and their joys and their
hobbies and give something even if it's
little to go off of so does that mean
that the greatest love story of all time
is actually the worst love story of all
time well that depends on what the play
is trying to get across and I think you
can make the argument that the play is
not about true love but rather about
young love many of us have been in love
when we were young in fact most of our
first loves came from when we were young
and do you remember what went through
your head at the time that's right
nothing but how gosh darn in love you
were it to matter what was wrong with
the person or whether or not it would
work in the long run all you knew is you
were in bliss and nothing could knock
you down from it what you have is
forever it feels so good it must last
forever but did it last forever for some
of us sure but for many we find these
feelings of certainty that we thought we
were experiencing we're really just our
reactions to first feeling these
emotions and chances are you broke up
and dated more in order to find the
right person but in a sense that's
what's so tragic about Romeo and Juliet
they were never allowed to go through
that because the families were so
determined to keep the two apart that
just convinced their inner
well that they loved each other even
more because as we all know when you're
young in love and other people tell you
it's not gonna work you're out of
control emotions want to prove even more
how wrong they are and you're gonna
fight harder and harder the more they
try to pull you apart and the more the
families push them away the more our
lovebirds yearn to be closer first align
then to marriage then to running away
and then ultimately to taking their
lives so perhaps the focus of the story
isn't as much the poetry of love as much
as the tragedy of prejudice if the
prejudice of the two families was never
there chances are their relationship
would be able to bloom much more
naturally they could discuss it with
people feel more comfortable wait it out
and see if this person is truly the one
but because such strong yet confusing
feelings are met with such hostility the
situation is dealt with more as a battle
as opposed to a union it becomes a fight
to create who you are and no longer a
discovery and thus that's why all are
punished it because everyone played a
part in the leading to their demise not
just the star-crossed lovers themselves
perhaps Shakespeare understood young
romance better than we thought he seems
to comprehend the strong emotions of
youth there were belly as choices they
caused and how damaging it can be when
the adults of the world are blinded by
hate and do not show proper guidance
maybe he had a greater understanding of
love that we didn't see the first time
around a story that shows what happens
when love is discovered but not allowed
to be explored how damaging closed minds
can be and how much can be prevented
through the simple act of accepting and
listening so I think in the end it is a
love story and a damn good one too
it just may take looking at it from a
more adult standpoint as opposed to a
young standpoint in order to figure that
out so it's a very strong possibility
that Shakespeare did know what he was
doing and was still the master that we
always thought he was before and not
even all the Claire Danes Leonardo
DiCaprio's or Baz Luhrmann's of the
world could diminish it how granted it
was a pretty good try I'm the Nostalgia
Critic guy remember it so you don't have
to